india is still battling a devastating
second wave of the pandemic
children may be among the least likely
to be killed by covet 19
but they suffer in other ways especially
when their own parents die from the
disease
dw's manira chowdhury reports from delhi
on how one organization
is trying to help the most vulnerable
for nine years now priti podar has
worked with children from
underprivileged communities
on a daily basis she deals with children
who have experienced
great loss and are forced to grow up
before they're ready
but since the outbreak of covert 19
their numbers are growing
children are being made to quit
education and take up household
responsibilities
and are also being pushed into child
labour as their families have lost
income secondly since they are spending
a lot of time at their home now
many cases of child abuse are also
coming up
having already been disproportionately
affected by covert 19
many children are facing another tragic
fallout of the pandemic
many have lost mothers or fathers or
both
leaving them extremely vulnerable since
last year the ngo where preeti works has
provided support to 13 children
who have been orphaned due to covet 19
by helping them settle in with their
extended families
sonal kapoor singh the founder of the
organization
says that while children who have been
orphaned have it much tougher
and need immediate attention a more
holistic approach is needed
to address every child in distress
there's a lot of conversation about
covered orphans
but honestly on the ground such cases
are probably five to six percent the
other 95
cases that we are looking at is where
the pair the very parents of these
children are pushing them into sexual
trade transactional sex and child labor
the real issue really is to look at the
vulnerability mapping
of which child is in you know massive
distress and which child needs more
support
that there is a need for a more
comprehensive approach is something that
anurag kundu
the head of the delhi commission for
protection of child rights
also advocates for i think first three
things need to happen one
the schemes that provide financial
assistance to these families
so that at least a basic subsistence is
insured
uh the second thing that needs to happen
is uh the governments
have to explore ways of keeping the
children in school
the third either ensuring a livelihood
for the family
or ensuring that they are registered in
different existing schemes of the
government could be a russian
or whatever but ensuring that the family
has adequate
means as an immediate urgent step
the commission has started a helpline
for children in distress
back at the center preeti says that many
children she meets with
are in crisis right now
because of kovitt years of hard work
that we and the children had put in
seem to have gone waste we are now
trying to get them back to their studies
and through different activities we are
trying to heal them
and help them come out of the difficult
situations they are facing
that despite their best efforts it will
be a long while before the children are
able to cope with the hurt
and the trauma that the pandemic has
inflicted
yasmin ali is india director for the
un's children's rights organization
unicef welcome to dw we saw there
hundreds of children have been orphaned
due to the pandemic
and there were already millions of
orphans before the pandemic hit
is there a system in place that makes
sure that these kids
are being looked after
well thank you for highlighting this
issue because it is really showing
the tip of the iceberg as you've heard
from your
your previous speakers where we do have
to pay
huge attention to the vulnerabilities
that children are facing due to the
pandemic
definitely those acute cases where
they're losing parents
care providers primary caregivers is
crucial
at the same time we have to keep in mind
the vulnerabilities that children
face as you talked about that they might
not be going back to school with school
reopens or they don't have access to
learning
or even access to the health care that
is needed
and i think what we're seeing is really
government and the
different partners coming together to
understand
that much more needs to be done to
strengthen that system to support
children
who are most vulnerable which means
identifying them
getting people to really flag these
cases where children are found to be
vulnerable
and to report them through the child
line through the
the state and district level women's and
child development
authorities so that they can be linked
to the
schemes that are available to support
them and their families
we're talking about immediate needs at
the moment what about psychological
effects because i can imagine losing
your parents in a situation like this
must be extremely traumatic for children
so who is helping them in that aspect
absolutely and that's really part of the
program that we're very
working very closely with the government
both at the new york
level and at the state level to look at
what is that
care package that children need it's the
immediate of course shelter
protection food nutrition etc but then
the psycho psychological impact of what
they are facing
is has been recognized very strongly and
we've been working together with neem
hands which is one of the premier
institutes looking at mental health
issues especially for children
in working with parents kinship care is
an important part of it
and any other avenue that might be
whether they're teachers or social
workers uh
or indeed uh the extended family who can
support children
on this we know that many people are
eager to help but that in itself has
presented a problem because more and
more orphans are
reportedly being put up for illegal
adoption on social media
what can you tell us about that
development
so what the social media flagging of
children
giving their names in particulars has
brought to the forefront is the need to
really
be very clear about who to report to uh
and and how not to go through social
media for such cases
india has a very strong child helpline
where
you can anyone can dial in 10 9 8
and be connected to the helpline which
will connect children
to the care and support that is needed
whether it's
through government departments or ngos
support or uh linking them to services
which will help them with their health
or any other vulnerability that they've
faced
so as trusting that system is going to
be extremely
important and we all need to support it
uh that way the cases are registered
adequately we've seen the government
coming up with
um a number of 577 who
have been registered so far so
the first point is how do we identify
them and register them and we
must use the system that that is being
put forward
many states have also developed their
own mechanisms
and so you know it's really how do we
buy into the mechanisms that have been
put in place
we'll have to leave it there yasmin ali
hak india director for
unicef thank you very much for joining
us
thank you for your interest